what's been the wildest and experience
you've had so far I have some root canal
done and I was in the chair and I'm
really scared of dentists and I was
there and they put the bleach in to like
clean through my teeth and I had a clown
in my jaw and they had like a plastic
kerbin things in my mouth and the
dentists left the room and the nurse
said
what was it like it was exactly haha
would we like to see more male nudity
right now on the show I'm going to shut
up I'm not sad thing so I don't have to
get my kit off next season to to fully
exam you see you can't really lose with
me because it's not
I refuse to bow down to public pressure
because thing about me and male nudity
is that everybody is served because it
will still get the boob count up
everybody wins
how's about that dragons are dire dire
wolves easier to kill
snakes who would you want to play if you
could play somebody else on your show so
sit on the stove Cersei Lannister
we were just talking about this
backstage because apparently there is a
quiz online which Game of Thrones
character are you have you guys has
anyone done this so you can go online
and you might see some basic multi
choice questions and what character are
you and I did it good um as Natalie
Dormer and I was area star cool but I've
never done it but I'll have to now I'm
fingers crossed again Cersei is gonna be
a Peter Dinklage I think she's gonna be
Terry when the lemon what was it like to
bite the hounds ear off and Rory Boers
had like two downstairs kick gran
don't stitched it what was it like Rory
yeah it was really good fun always
wanted when she punched me aim that the
risk connections going on there between
the legs best moment of my life was
horrible
when she bit my year second best man
well kind of take look to be honest get
off me
I thought he got off lightly
nasty [ __ ]
which mommy
may I see I think I speak about most of
us here better I had to light we are to
see you intact
if you had an opportunity to play any
superhero who would it be
I would pay spider-man because because
um the typical superhero look is this
strong muscly big character and I like
the spider-man is kind of a gel and not
that and like kind of unsuspecting as
well rather than like coming out and
like lifting up a car it's like yeah I
don't know I feel like it's a lot more
subtle than that yeah it's fine man
hi Natalie in the rest of the cast I
wonder who your questions for questions
for George oh um the one thing I've
always wanted to ask you for years is um
Hodor Hodor
you